[Musik]
doch geklappt und jetzt kommen beim ein
video
es ist so warm hier was ist das denn ein
spiel aus dem alex workshop ganz oben in
der wir sind mainz willkommen bei mir
ich hoffe natürlich gibt's einen gut und
zwar es kam er letzte woche dienstag
mein video youtube videos mit 0 1
das video ist echt ich das sehe komme
ich wieder gefreut und der top kommentar
unter diesem video war alex macht doch
mal ein video in dem du dir youtube
videos anschaut mit den meisten dislike
und ich kann dir ist und nur sachen wie
oder every day spa oder so schaue ich
mir nicht an das kind ja alles ich habe
mich so ein paar videos genommen die ich
selber nicht kannte
die aber echte menge des werks haben die
chance etwas zusammen an wenn ihr auch
mal bock hab auch instagram bilder mit
den meisten reicht dann lassen wir noch
nach oben
und ich habe mir überlegt unter allen
die daumen nach oben doch dass wir da
unter allen die in die kommentare
schreiben heftig alex eshop handlungen
sich das hier verliebte also hier
insgesamt vier wie das ausgesucht ich
will eigentlich gar nicht lange aber
jetzt fange einfach mal an mit dem
ersten und zwar mit cortado portal
youtube 700.000 life 2 millionen ist
leicht wie ein franz millionen hughes
ist das auf jeden fall eine krasse zahl
noch ist keine ahnung warum das
zweimillionste sein soll ich mein ich
verstehe nicht aber kommando ich will
ein bisschen vor dieser schönen rausch
sind 100.000 flaschen
mein größter respekt
jetzt hast du eine scheibe und das tut
mir auch da schon ein bisschen weh
obwohl ich das selber mal gemacht habe
ich war nicht so fest davon überzeugt
dass ich in zwei monaten millionen habe
und an diesem goldenen kriegen
erläuterte klopp
[Musik]
in
sie sitzen
die auch einfach diese silberne teil
auseinander gesägt und das war's viele
fans millionen klicks ok ich meine ich
habe ja auch im video gemacht wo ich
mein playmate zerstört habt das hat
glaube ich nur 2006 leicht oder so und
nicht zwei millionen
wir machen weiter mit johnny leoni
johnny johnny es papa 1,1 milliarden
aufrufe und nur 600.000 ist ja was heißt
nur aber ich meine 10 14 jahre news und
600.000 ist ja gar nicht so schlecht
doch diese pollen wie so eine scheiße
1,1 milliarden klicks dass die eine
stunde schrieb video was passiert ich
komme halt ganz klar was ist das für
mich tut mir sehr leid aber hier muss
ich auf jeden fall auch mal kurz das
leichter
wir machen weiter und zwar habe ich
ihren video gefunden
von justin bieber aber ich vorher noch
nie gesehen wahrscheinlich die einen von
euch sollten das kennen aber es hat
301.000
[Musik]
es musste was warmes zu tun haben sie
mir dass man sagen ich verstehe absolut
nicht im sinn hinter diesem video
wie ist das zu stande gekommen also
heute keine angst wenn ihr noch nie beim
zahnarzt war nein ihr seid danach nicht
so drauf wie er gerade keine ahnung was
das war ich verstehe es überhaupt nicht
jammern schon zum nächsten welt baby
victoria katana make-up viel über
200.000 ist leichter kommt los geht's
[Musik]
was ist das für eine scheiße
ohne witz wer guckt sich so etwas an
ich kann mir nicht mal vorstellen als
kleine kinder du was cool finden oder
witzig christi medien nicht
er ist gibt es zur option ist sehr
schlimm und ich habe mich so was sagen
denn ihre mitschülerin dazu ich meine
dies noch kein baby mehr die ist ja
bestimmt von 10 oder so also leute wie
gesagt rainer bock auf instagram bilder
mit den meisten leicht ludwig meter ich
habe erst mal was ähnlich macht auf
jeden fall dann lasst man nach oben da
ansonsten schreibt alex stoff in die
kommentare unter allen jetzt machen
verlose ich dieses wunderschöne t shirt
auf jeden fall auch mal gerne einen
block vorbei wenn ich ein bisschen
unterstützen wollt oder so einfach mal
ganz auf meine jedem steuer verlangt
ansonsten nehmen uns übermorgen wieder
natürlicher den film kurzum eingeblendet
haut rein